three million subscribers that is an
absolutely incredible number and thank
you all so much for believing in me and
usually on these milestone videos I
would make a montage of the videos I've
done in the past or the events that
we've had but in actuality I find myself
looking back at myself when I started
this YouTube channel a little over two
years ago
and I look back at those videos and I
see basically a child standing in front
of a camera nervously spouting out
whatever comes to his mind which is
exactly what I'm doing right now but I
look back and I see all the potential
that we had and for the first time in my
life I look back and I don't want to
change a thing you know I've had regrets
in my life and I've had downturns and
I've had bad moments but I wouldn't I
wouldn't get rid of any of them I
wouldn't change a thing because it led
me to this point and made me the person
that I am standing in front of you and
I've had so many of you guys come up and
say hi to me and tell me about how my
videos where I have changed your life or
influenced you or made your lives better
and that is intimidating and originally
I thought that I may not be ready for
that responsibility and but to hear you
guys tell me how much I inspire you and
how much I make your lives better that's
what that's what influences me to be
better and that's what inspires me to be
a better person and that's why I Drive
myself every day to do better not only
in terms of the videos that I make and
I'm so glad that you guys enjoy the
videos that I make and that I can make
you laugh and then I can entertain you
guys and then it's the biggest joy in my
life but also that we stand strong as a
community of over three million people
we stand strong and United as one of the
best forces for good on the internet not
just YouTube but together we can do
literally anything and we have done so
much raising so much money for charity
and putting in the minds of so many
people that we can do good
and that we should because if we don't
and I don't take advantage of this
community we have built none taking
advantage but pointing you in the
direction to do good and if I don't
steer you in that direction then I have
done wrong and that I have lost purpose
and lost sight of what we can do as a
community and what you guys can do as
individuals it's not just togetherness
but every single one of you matters and
every single one of you can change the
world in your own way and together we
are so strong and that is the most
amazing thing to come out of this
channel and to see myself grow as the
person and entertainer that I am and go
from there to here and notice that
hardly a damn thing has changed but just
to see that you guys have rallied and
believed in me and inspired me to make
myself a better person I want you guys
to believe that you all can do whatever
you want and you guys can do it to
change the world so thank you all so
much for uniting for our goals and thank
you so much for believing in this
channel in this cause and before I get
to rambling here because I have a
tendency to do that
I've prepared a few more things that I
want to show for you guys and I want you
guys to be excited because if we've come
this far in two years just imagine what
we could do in the next two we've come
so far in such a short amount of time I
mean just a little over two years ago I
went from doing this which admittedly is
really cool and I love doing it but not
exactly high budget so having the
resources to be able to do whatever I
want and I
I have that now you guys have given me
the chance and I don't own this but I'm
renting it and for the immediate future
it's still mine and I can use it to make
whatever I want and I am so excited for
all the videos that I'm gonna be able to
make out of this it's it's it's awesome
it's exactly what I wanted when I first
started doing YouTube and I never ever
imagined that I'd actually get to this
point and I would never ever be able to
do it without you guys so that's a
little sneak peek of what's to come in
the future and I have never been more
excited about what we can do in the
future and the things that we can create
and how many people we can collaborate
with and make these awesome videos that
are just going to be fun and
entertaining and hopefully that you guys
can enjoy while at the same time leading
people towards a common good and it's
not just the community that we share I
want you to know as an individual and I
know there's hundreds of thousands of
people watching this but I'm speaking to
you one-on-one right now because I'm
just a guy standing in front of a camera
with no pants on I'm just one guy who is
hoping and praying that everyone
actually believes what I'm saying and
wants to be better and do good in the
world but you as an individual you have
to take responsibility to be the leader
that no one else will if we all take
that responsibility together then it's a
shared burden across the entire
community but you have to stand up and
believe in yourself even if you don't
believe in yourself now know that I
believe in you with all my heart I
believe that you can do good in this
world and that you can be a force for
good because there's nothing stronger
than the power of one person decides to
do something and I'm just one guy here
that people decided to believe in but
you can do amazing things and I know
that you can because I did it and I'm a
screw-up I've done stupid things and I'm
just an idiot in front of a camera
making silly voices and doing silly
videos that hopefully people enjoy and
I can do that you can do even more you
can do so much more we together can do
so much more and I'm so excited and I'm
so happy for the future and I hope that
you believe in me the same way that I
believe in what we're doing here and the
good that we're spreading across the
world so thank you all so much and thank
you so much and before we go I've got
one more thing I've been challenged to
do certain challenge but I never do
things exactly as the rules say so let's
just move right to it all right so I've
been challenged to do the ALS ice bucket
challenge but I never do things exactly
as people tell me - Oh real nice bad
challenge okay thank you pull up okay so
I bet you how to do twice house all the
game pros jacksepticeye yamimash wait
charlie anyone else you feel like doing
it did you also I'm gonna donate to some
shops necklace as well thank you also
you